indeed administered Kashmir was divided
into two new federal territories last
month jamaat-e-islami has mobilised
support over the past two weeks to
highlight what it says is a forgotten
issue the poor state of the Kashmiri
economy is also a major concern through
the party
our correspondent Kemal Haider says
Pakistanis nationwide have shown their
solidarity with Kashmir by the
right-wing jamaat-e-islami which is here
to show that they support the people of
Kashmir and are against the atrocities
being meted out by the Indian security
forces in India administered with me the
purpose of the rally is to highlight the
atrocities being committed by India
against the Kashmir ease and to draw the
world's attention to their plight if
Modi has not stopped it will become a
problem for the minorities in India and
will also have dangerous consequences
for the world women and children and of
course while there may be some criticism
of the government the purpose of this
rally is to show that the people of
Pakistan care about a Kashmiri brothers
living on the other side of the line of
divine